we shouldn't agree on everything like
this concept that we've become so
egotistical that we need everybody to
see the world exactly how you see it the
beauty is that people see different
we need much more compassion
not just empathy compassion to
understand that everybody's life's
Journeys brought them to their views
when people here today you pitch your
business idea and somebody says I don't
like it they're not being mean they're
not a piece of they don't want your
idea
good like I don't remember anybody
liking any of the that most worked
out for me like you need to be within
yourself and deploy kindness to others
nobody who's judging you is a reflection
on you you need to fall in love with
yourself first everything else figures
itself out